brothers and sisters just imagine for a
second that you give £10 in donation and
that £10 is used to buy food or bricks
or whatever to help the people in Gaza
but then just imagine this amazing be
that you want to do but we turn it into
a money-making machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian Brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true click the link below and
donate brothers and sisters and dear
friends I hope you guys are well inah we
are going to be reacting to the debate
between what's his name Mahi Hassan and
and Elon Levy I think Elon the scumbag
have you guys watched debate yes yeah
yes okay interesting I got some bits
that I've um screen recorded
let's react to cuz I think it was I
think who do you think won all every day
it yeah just like with you and Craig
David okay here's the first part yeah
convince the people of Gaza terrorism is
a dead end there is no light at the end
of that tunnel you also get to respond
you can respond to answer you you you I
mean I think Peter made the point very
eloquently it's a nonsensical War aims
the real war aims of course are what the
Israeli Minister say when smotri says
the aim of the war is to annihilate Gaza
that is the aim I take face value he
literally said that and when they say
this stuff when they talk about
resettling Gaza when they talk about
staying in Gaza that is what
they finish an answer he's trying to
occupy the debate not government policy
and those against government I would
just I would just say this I say this
you want to convince the people of Gaza
that terrorism is a dead end then stop
inflicting terrorism on
them he has some sick wom bars like what
what did you think of that specific that
cuz there's two more no there's a few
there's that I saw you want to watch all
together yeah why not why not okay let's
go through the next one okay hostage P
if you want to show them you you're
welcome
to P it on show them you I am in daily
contact I tell them I will do whatever
it takes to help you get your kids
home allow him to respond you've got
your bit of stage craft please take it
let's be clear you saw very very
performative outrage there from Alon
there to be clear don't you lecture me
about hostages when your government has
killed more hostages than it has rescued
that's on you that's on you I will
happily support this pin because I
support the release of all the hostages
and I support I support the release of
thousands of Palestinian detainees being
raped and tortured and Sil do you
support that do you support the release
of Palestinians I do not support support
releasor children let's get some space
here he can't answer the question I
support the release he should have told
him you know when he's grabbing onto him
he's that don't touch me yeah yeah why
is he grabbing on to him right when he
drops the bombshell right at the end
that are you going to support the
release of the thousands of detainees go
yeah yeah he even condemn the don't get
too close yeah he even condemn the the
great the the rape and the things that's
been happening in that
CID Camp yeah and the last video Israel
are Justified look the argument is
pretty simple tonight and pretty
hypocritical from Alon what we've heard
tonight is that October that nothing
justifies October the 7th but October
the 7th justifies everything well I'm
here tonight to tell you no October the
7th does not justify everything it does
not justify the suffering in Gaza it
does not justify the killing of kids in
Gaza it does not justify the starvation
in Gaza it does not justify the rape and
torture of Palestinian detainees which
Alon refused to condemn tonight it does
not justify any of that it doesn't
justify the tearing up the Geneva
conventions the Defiance of
international law and the ICC and our
own Ley law yes October the 7th was a
war crime but the response to a war
crime is not to commit your own series
of war crimes on an epic scale 33 times
as many people killed since October the
7th as were killed on October the 7th
and I'll say this to you look very very
clearly if you support this motion
tonight you are opening the gates of
hell not just in Gaza but globally
because every dictator and Tyrant around
the world will say Israel's actions were
justif IFI then so am mine Putin Assad
Kim they all say Israel killed kids
Israel killed Aid workers Israel killed
journalists so can we and I will be I
will be very clear I will be very clear
with you tonight if you are here tonight
ladies and gents if you're here tonight
to defend what Israel's done knowing
full well what Israel has done if you're
defending the human suffering in Gaza
the amputation of little kids if you're
doing that in full knowledge then you're
not just here to defend the indefensible
or Justify the unjustifiable I'm sorry
you're a sociopath
and I will say to
you I mean what do you make out I mean
one of the main points that I loved was
they say nothing justifies October the
7th but everything bro that was that was
like wow that's actually the hypocrisy
bro nothing justifies what they did on
7th of October okay but they justify
everything they're doing because of
October 7th that's right I mean just
recently what happened with in Lebanon
with the attacks the IDF attacks on
Lebanon we don't call that the 22nd of
whatever September yes we don't have a
name for that even though like maybe 3
400 civilians died in one day which is
comparable with what they call October
the 7th yes so why don't we have dates
that we can also commemorate in that way
yeah you know um you have to say that
actually to be honest with you the pro
Zionist if you like propaganda in this
very specific regard has been successful
that they've been able to coin certain
terms they've said October the 7th
they're human shield these kind of
buzzword and things that the we have to
deconstruct that and we have to
reconstruct our own versions of that
yeah because if October the 7th becomes
a buzzword such that a thousands
people's death uh with I don't know how
many of it onethird of it is you know uh
military targets anyway yeah and the
rest compar now we can use this as he's
mentioned to justify the killing of 30
times more than that then this is it's
it's ridiculous it's a double standard
of tremendous
portions so uh I mean now the reason why
lebnon is very relevant is because
lebnan is a sovereign state which has
not declared war I mean take the example
of the pager thing for example exactly
look the pager thing let me ask you a
question and let's think about this
together right the pager thing if one of
these let's
sayah targets had been in the United
Kingdom in London rather than Beirut he'
been in London he's been on a train in
London and then they detonated the bomb
that's just for the sake of argument go
down in history and then one of the
children on the bus one white boy yeah
white English boy was killed yeah would
that be called a terrorist attack by
consensus yes it would so if a if a
Lebanese boy in a sovereign state which
is Lebanon which is not at war with the
so-call state of Israel is killed it's
not seen as an act of terrorism but if a
white boy under the same circumstances
was it would be called an act of
terrorism it already shows you what's
going on what's going on is that there's
a double standard of tremendous
proportions and they've got a hierarchy
of who they considered to be uh blood
worth saving yeah exactly and blood
that's not worth saving you saw that in
the Ukraine war where they will come and
say this this is something that you see
in the Middle East or these things it's
like they were saying this belongs there
people the children can be killed there
not here you saw this with journalis
journalists uh I think uh Norman finlin
said this as well he said that in six
months the children that have been
murdered butchered in 6 months in Gaza
are more than all the other War zones
over 3 years multiplied by four wow and
this exemplifies the point of M Hassan
that he's saying that it seems that
you're just you're saying that
everything is justified through October
7th he another child through these
exploding Pages this is this is Warfare
by a complete Rogue State that's not
being held to account in fact Israel is
a threat to the Middle East let let me
guys let me tell you guys something yeah
it was and also like why did you find
was it the head of not head of CIA but
someone connected CIA he said this was
this could be seen as like this is an
one of the greatest acts of terrorism
the pager thing exploding you you
basically planting explosives in Pages
bro anyone no one's free I think in
2022 there was a vote to turn the Middle
East into a nuclear free zone but there
was only one country that voted against
against that two guesses uh it's a hard
one it was Israel oh no really I was
thinking
Lebanon so the the the country that's
saying oh we're surrounded and oh this
is happening and it they're the ones
attacking in Syria there are reports to
suggest that they are even like Isis
people that are injured members of Isis
they're taking them in and they're
healing them and they're helping them
they you know they've got issues going
on in Syria they've got issues going on
Lebanon they've got issues going on in
Gaza it seems like these guys are the
thorn in the backside of the Middle East
everywhere and this Thorn yeah and this
Thorn needs to be removed yeah exactly I
mean yeah like to me that he he wiped
the floor with with them and nothing can
justify it and you know you can see this
guy doesn't he's talking about hostages
and when I say The Thorn needs to be
removed I mean the issue needs to be
corrected just before they say that no
no this Zionist well whoever they are
they need to be arrested get rid of them
legally you know in that uh in that
instance and you can see they are the
Thorns the other and the whole world has
woken up to this you know this this word
of anti-Semitism it's lost its value you
know you guys are the biggest anti-at
yourself you've made it more dangerous
for innocent Jews who do not condone
what you're doing to walk out Freedom
which is you know we talk about this
like there was one U guy who was in
Stanford walking he got attacked you
know I went out there myself to Stanford
and went to the Jewish community and
spoke about this how how he was um um
disgusted with what happened because why
there an innocent man an old old man
Jewish man walking uh get attacked but
this is what you guys have caused you're
trying to make the state of Israel a
place that's safe for um the the Jews
but it's it's the opposite but you're a
Muslim guy talking about all the
weaponization of anti-Semitism there was
a woman called shulamit alone who won
the 2,000 Israel prize and she said and
I quote Yeah
anti-Semitic it's a trick we always use
it to stifle legitimate criticism of
Zionist Israel yeah in fact she was a
former Israeli Cabinet member as well
well exactly I mean they quite honest
with this but you can see that people
like Candace Owens and many of them have
come out now because the world has woken
up to this reality and I believe
genuinely I believe uh Israel's days are
numbered as a state we want it to go
back to where the Muslims and the
Christians and the Jews lived in those
lands for centuries together away from
these zionists who are against Judaism
they don't even believe in God for that
matter they talk about the Holy lands
you don't even believe in in you most
most of you guys are atheists you just
need to look into unus where Muslims
ruled over Spain for 800 years and
convenia what's that yeah that's where
you know the Muslims Christians and Jews
they liveed together until Isabel FD
came and and do you know how they
tortured the Jews and Oho they ran to
the otom Ottomans they run to yeah they
run to Ottomans for Save Haven so the
the issue is very clear this SC what's
name on Elon what's hison what's his
name Aon Levy Alon the coward yeah this
is what he is flipping absolute he
got he got mean is brilliant at this you
know one class debate and the thing is
is that it's it's a combination of
intellectual points that he put forward
but also rhetorical yes um you know
presentation and I think he's one of the
best in the world really especially on
this issue yeah and what was good about
his um debate was that he's
actually able to kind of present his own
primary resource material cuz he's he's
the one doing these interviews with a
lot of these like Israeli
representatives and stuff so he'll take
what he said with such and such a person
and say well I interviewed such and such
a person do you know what I mean it has
a um a power to it when you do it like
that I think yeah it's good I mean it
was brilliant you guys saw it for
yourself I think the full interview the
the debate is on zto has got this new
media z z yeah it's on there and there
was one journalists trying to
question her where the funding comes
from that but you can see they're just
looking for any kind of excuse what's
wrong with even if it is you got Israel
God knows lobbies go does so many with
how many media platforms here in the in
the UK and you have an issue let's
suppose it's funded byar what's your
point look at you you Hypocrites subh
you Zionist fund God knows Hollywood all
kind of media platforms so anyways you
can watch that in there and um yeah
that's all I've say any last words guys
no that's it may Allah bless you brother
and sisters inshah and Caron supporting
our brothers and sisters around the
world and making this in you guys play a
massive role share Caron in do not
forget
brother and sisters what happened and
like Matthew said and what did Matthew
say he said um you know nothing
justifies by the seventh but October the
7th justifies everything was a good play
on that that that I'm going to be using
anytime use yourit as well that was
amazing keep it in